le groupe rouge et noir jouent ensemble
depuis trois saisons
dans cette finale de coupe des yvelines
de futsal il compte bien s'appuyer sur
cette cohésion pour faire tomber l'ogre
parisien une certaine pression parce
qu'on joue contre une bonne équipe de
paris cap a perdu cette année contre qui
on a fait deux bons résultats surtout le
dernier et puis ça sachant qu'on n'avait
pas notre équipe complète donc bannis
des c'est d'essayer de faire un résultat
et de les faire tomber
surtout en district d une veine étant
donné qu'ils ont perdu aucun match cette
année
une finale qui fait office dommage il y
a quinze jours le club a perdu le moteur
de sa section futsal michel bonvalet
l'entraîneur houdanais a donc demandé
une minute de silence avant le coup
d'envoi
mais voilà avec 20000 euros de budget
annuel pour le psg et deux équipes
n'évoluent pas dans la même catégorie
si la première occasion et où dannez la
supériorité technique parisienne fait
rapidement son oeuvre
le jeu de passes et de redoublement us
des rouge et noir conséquence à la 7e
minute le psg ouvre le score rapidement
trop rapidement
les joueurs de frédéric leclerc ne
semble pas savoir comment défendre et
les buts s'enchaînent 4 0 à la mi temps
les rouge et noir doivent se réveiller
on a une tactique de jeu en première mi
temps qui faisait que voilà on voulait
défendre en zone est derrière bon on a
pas eu on a eu quelques buts un peu
hasardeuse se passe entre les jambes
c'est des petits buts un peu de rap
fonds qu'ils ont mis malgré les bonnes
intentions retour des vestiaires ou dans
se fait cueillir à nouveau à la 33e
minute pour éviter une défaite aux
allures de correction les rouge et noir
font parler leur orgueil ils retrouvent
leur agressivité leur impact et débloque
enfin leur compteur
mais les parisiens invaincus en
championnat cette saison sont
impitoyables et plantent deux nouvelles
banderilles pour mener cette bizarre
hein les joueurs de frédéric de claire
inscriront un second but pour l'honneur
score final 8 2 ou dans ne lèvera pas la
quatrième coupe des yvelines de son
on est des difficultés quand même à
rentrer dans le match ils ont pris
directement l'ascendant sur nous ils
étaient bien en place tactiquement ça
bougeait beaucoup on a eu du mal et bon
faut accepter la défaite un com com et
les voilà et en deuxième mi temps c'est
vrai qu'on a une petite réaction
d'orgueil on s'est dit bon dans le
vestiaire on s'est dit les gars faut pas
même joué on s'est libéré un peu voilà
le plaisir avant tout c'est ce qui
fonctionne bien et puis c'était quand
même d'un genou
malgré la défaite les rouge et noir
continueront de prendre une histoire
ensemble sur le terrain car c'est de là
que woods en tire sa force